foreign
dos Santos one of the directors of
Spider-Man across the spider-verse it's
such an honor to get to sit here with
you dude how are you doing uh the honors
all mine I'm doing great yeah yeah
um I want to start off because you know
you've done a lot of projects in the
past and you've you've worked in
different departments but this one is
really special for you because this is
your feature directorial debut correct
it is yeah it's a it's a different Beast
yeah actually I think it's all all three
directors featured directories that was
that was uh you already answered sorry
it's okay
um I was gonna say how does it feel to
have your first movie release in IMAX
it's unbelievable I mean IMAX to me was
like the equivalent of a roller coaster
you know it's it's like
it's like the movie event so the idea
that something that I was a part of uh
is on IMAX it's at surreal yeah and
you're gonna see your name it's gonna be
bigger than life very strange all very
strange cool but strange the sound in
this movie is is so important to
everything that else that's going on you
know was there a moment specifically
that you felt the sound was something
that you wanted to focus in on and make
super impactful for that moment yeah I
mean there so I think one thing that
really sets this film apart from other
you know feature animated stuff is
there's actually Quiet Moments When I
say quiet I don't mean absent of sound I
mean it's just beautiful ambient
you know sort of white noise the city
noise the noise of the city
um this film lets those scenes really
ride
and taking that in and seeing those
moments between miles and Gwen and
hearing that you know I
again it's it's sort of it's surreal to
be a part of something like that
something that that took that chance uh
and and let the sound do do the heavy
lifting this movie has some super deep
Cuts in terms of like the fandom and the
Spider-Man lore of the characters and
different multiverses they're in
um how is your fandom kind of influenced
that storytelling
my personal fandom I mean look you know
uh I've I've said this to to some other
people but you know I I've only known a
life with Spider-Man in it uh so our
family crest I was born in Portugal
my middle name is aranya which means
spider in Portuguese
um and our family crest is the spider so
one of the first like images that I have
waking up in bed is John romita seniors
sort of classic Spider-Man cover I had a
big poster on my wall so my fandom is
literally like day one fandom
um I grew up you know formative years
was in the sort of mid to late 90s and
this was sort of the Todd McFarland era
you know and then the post Todd
McFarland era when everybody had the
mass Exodus and went to Image Comics and
the clone saga happened so all bringing
all that I mean it's it's everything you
know uh my my fandom I don't know if
it's like
I definitely planted a flag for Scarlet
Spider to to take on that that classic
90s look
um but yeah I mean I think it's the
fandom is sort of part of my DNA at this
point well I mean you can feel it too
like it's it's one of those films that I
feel like you actually know that a fan
made that because you're sitting there
there's no other way it could have been
done like that's just to be honest like
it's one of those things that I feel
like audiences are going to appreciate
and I certainly did so I'm very excited
to uh get to sing your Praises
um I want to know you know the first
film
was so well known for the music you know
and and that's one of the things that
people still hearken back to I think you
guys did a great job at carrying that
into this film and I would just kind of
love to zero in on that and ask you know
what was it like when you were planning
what music slash artist collabs you were
going to do for the film and part two to
that is are there any artists or songs
that you didn't get to include that you
would have loved to I mean as far as
yeah what we let me answer the first
part first
um I think the great thing about
animation uh and the fact that this has
taken us four years to make is that it's
highly highly iterative you know we're
making multiple versions of this film
before the final thing that you see on
screen so we've tried every song Under
the Sun we have an amazing music
department spring uh is is sort of got
her finger on the pulse of everything
that uh that is coming out
uh and that has been that has already
been
um so we sort of have like The Pick of
the litter you know uh we're really
lucky in that regard and again this is a
huge team effort so
you know truth be told I'm sort of over
staging scenes and action sequences and
these sort of like dramatic beats while
the music department is running and
placing songs and and trying new things
and running them past Phil Chris Camp
um the only way this film gets made is
if we're sort of splitting duties that
way so there were plenty of times where
you know I'd watch a scene for the first
time in editorial and be like whoa this
track is sick
no that's awesome I you kind of led into
something I was going to ask too because
you know uh you worked with two other
great filmmakers on this and I'm just
curious like how is it you know working
with a team of directors you know and
and could you talk to that a little bit
sure
I mean I think we liken ourselves to
sort of a a jazz Trio you know we play
really good jazz with each other it
really helps
um you know Kemp comes from an amazing
screenwriting background he was a
journalist he brings this sort of like
life experience into anything that he
does
um and Justin I mean look the guy was
responsible for you know the visuals of
the first spider-verse film which you
know
I wasn't a part of but I can tell you
from the outside looking in was a
seismic shift across the entire industry
um and I'm predominantly you know sort
of a story artist really focused on
camera sort of you know whatever's
happening with the with the characters
you know within the frame
um so our powers sort of like occupy
these these
you know different areas of filmmaking
and we kind of complement each other
really well at the beginning of the film
I'd say like the first year and a half
we were across every meeting together
so we had that time to kind of like
Bond and figure out what each other's
tastes were and where we were leaning
and where we could count on each other
for everything and then once the film
really started picking up production and
we had to kind of split off and go our
separate ways we'd see each other in the
Halls you know go one go into one
meeting and going to the other and we
sort of high five and go like you got
the thing you got the thing I got the
thing so it works it worked out well
that way you could have recreated the
Spider-Man meme yeah absolutely
I hope that happened at some point I
don't know if it did or if it was ever
discussed or maybe we're pretty close
Okay okay I mean you did it there's that
moment in the film which you know has
already been in the promotional material
but you guys took that to a whole nother
level yeah so you might have just
created a new meme whether or not you
know that the mix of live action and
animation is something that to me stood
out in this film
um and I'm just curious if you could
speak to that and kind of you know it's
not something that I think many people
would think going in like oh my God
we're going to see different real
live-action things that maybe hearken to
other cool stuff could you speak to that
a little bit look I think you know
anytime
um you take a chance with a film like
this
you know you the first film took all the
chances really you know I think the
first film opened up these doors
creatively for us to just stomp right
through and do whatever the heck we
really wanted to do
um so I think you know posts are
pre-spider bursts I don't know that that
you know mixing live action with with
with animation the way we did works that
well look there's Mary Poppins it worked
beautifully in Mary Poppins
um but this is a different a different
sort of thing and connecting those lines
and sort of hinting that like this is a
big shared
space
um it was really fun
but I think without the first film I
don't know that we have the permission
to do that well I almost feel like you
you took the permission and you excelled
at the test I think you're right I think
I think we sort of like kicked it as far
in as we could go and and and look I I
think there's still room to grow you
know I think there's there's a movie
Beyond this one
um and there's who knows you know
speaking to you know being a fan of this
stuff as a fan I know what I wanted to
the ending to the film was crazy
obviously we don't we're not going to
talk about exactly what happens but I do
want to talk about the impact of where
it leaves off and how you think fans are
going to react I think we have the
benefit of being the second act of this
three-act play
um and with a second act you know
there's there's darker tones there's a
lower point that the character needs to
go through that as a creative is really
exciting to explore once we decided
you know where we wanted this to end we
went all in not only did we know you
know we were going to put miles on his
heels but there's this twist at the end
that I think if people you know are sort
of leading and sort of saying like I
think I know where this is going then it
goes and takes this this left turn yeah
yeah it was more like a slam in the face
the best possible slam hopefully but
yeah I mean I think creatively that's
that's the fun stuff you know that's the
stuff that once we really dialed that in
um I remember the moment in editorial
where everybody sort of looked at each
other and went and this was that
storyboard phase this was before you
know there was pretty graphics on on
screen what
this is this is Juicy yeah yeah I could
uh there's only a few Cliffhangers in
film history that I would say or I'm a
little more impactful than that so I
think it's really awesome
um if you had to like identify as one of
the Spider-Man in this film
who would it be and why
I would say I mean look I'm not saying
this because he's the star of the film
but it is Miles Morales um I think it's
Miles Morales well let me just say it's
the Morales family because
you know we've all grown up with parents
who might have been hovering around and
uh being overprotective and
to me that's the thing that binds this
whole film together we can go across all
the multiverses we can go across all the
craziest Landscapes you can imagine
what we really hold on to is that
relationship between miles and his
parents
um so I've been on miles's side I've had
those those you know breaks with with my
mom where she wasn't stoked and I was
storming out the door and later
apologized for everything I said and now
I'm on the other side I'm a dad and I've
got a seven-year-old and all the
directors they've all you know funny
thing about Kemp is that he's got a kid
that was literally miles's age you know
going off to college while he was making
this film and going through the parents
Journey my kids seven we went to soccer
practice and I was holding his hand and
he pulled his hand away from from mine
he said Dad don't hold my hand my
friends are over there and I was like
and gutted me you know as as a father
but I knew that's part of the journey
last question why should fans experience
this film in IMAX they can see that
it's going to fill their entire eyeballs
it's going to fill you know
their brain uh the sound in this thing
is absolutely insane they're going to be
ensconced in visuals
that they've never experienced before
and you can only do that on IMAX